as each our past our ability to move
safely in Kurdish Northeast Syria
lessened fewer and fewer civilians were
on the roads
almost everyone else had gone these
families grouped together are living in
trucks they're so confused by the
fighting they want to be able to move in
any direction at any given time they
fled Aleppo six years ago they're
fleeing again now this was the start of
a remarkable 24 hours here the fighting
between Turkish back militia and Kurds
intensified along a huge battlefield
nobody knew though what was happening in
the chaos hundreds of Islamic state
fighters and Families escaped and
suddenly terror groups sleeper cells
were activated Kurdish intelligence said
our hotel was a target bringing panic to
the de facto capital commissioner
on the streets soldiers restricted
traffic roadblocks into this area of the
city were reinforced we were forced in
the Logan to a safe house a Turkish led
invasion a spike in Islamic state
activity and then this we watched the
pictures as they came in there was
disbelief an air attack on a civilian
convoy heading to act as human shields
against the fighting the death toll grew
its then they realized their grip on
their homeland a Cobra Java was slipping
away and then another twist by nighttime
the news nobody expected so quickly
the Kurds had done a deal with Russia
and Syria our Kurdish colleagues were in
shock the night sky is filled with
tracer bullets and gunfire in
celebration a celebration by the Arab
communities here the regime of Bashar
al-assad was returned
we had to leave the Damascus government
considers us illegal and consorting with
terrorists
it's a 12-year sentence messages came
through the Syrian military would take
control of the border to Iraq in four
hours we were three hours away the
collapse of Kurdish series
administration after our friends utterly
disconsolate we made the final crossing
from a java leaving the Kurds behind and
leaving the next generation displaced
from their homes and camping in schools
where there will be taught in Arabic not
Kurdish from now on
Raghava was a dream but it's gone for
sure though the children will learn one
thing in Kurdish that is the meaning of
betrayal still Ramsay skynews in
Northeast Syria